[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans l'entretien
sur France 24 notre invité est le
ministre ukrainien des Affaires
étrangères mitro couliba il est avec
nous depuis Kiev merci d'être avec nous
le plaisir est pour moi ce vendredi une
frappe de missile dans le sud de
l'Ukraine à ZAPA tué de nombreux civils
la Russie vous accuse d'être responsable
quel est votre réponse
c'est un mensonge il y a des indications
très nettes y compris des indications
publiques que c'est la Russie qui
continue de frapper des villes du
krainienne passe à nos appareils ni pro
Nicolas et d'autres villes pacifiques
est-ce que vous pouvez confirmer que
cette frappe visait des civils
je n'ai pas encore reçu les tous
derniers renseignements
mais à partir de ce que c'est
actuellement oui pensez-vous que c'est
la première conséquence de l'annexion de
vaporizia et de trois autres régions par
la Russie ou des soi-disant référendums
se sont tenus il y a quelques jours
non je ne le crois pas c'est dans le
prolongement de cette attit terroriste
russe qui cherche à terrifier les villes
ukrainiennes et menaces
littéralement menace chaque ville et
village en Ukraine
quel que soit la distance par rapport au
front
c'est soi-disant référendum qui se sont
tenus à zaporriggia à Carson à Luant ce
qui a donné ce que font que ces
territoires sont dorénavant annexés à la
Russie qu'est-ce que ça change
concrètement sur le terrain pour
l'Ukraine strictement rien nous allons
continuer de libérer nos territoires
ça ne change rien pour le moment non
plus
cette déclaration très forte du
secrétaire général qui disait clairement
que c'est similacre de référendum et les
indexations qui vont se produire se font
en violant la Charte des Nations Unies
et s'oppose complètement avec les
objectifs de paix de sécurité à travers
le monde donc l'Ukraine va continuer de
résister c'est partenaires vont
continuer de la soutenir est-ce que cela
signifie la fin de toute discussion
diplomatique il a eu un échange de
prisonniers il a eu un accord sur les
grains est-ce que c'est la fin de toute
discussion avec la Russie directe ou
indirecte
comme le disait notre président très
clairement ces derniers temps lorsqu'il
s'est adressé au Conseil de sécurité des
Nations unies il a dit que
si la Russie devait tenter d'annexer nos
territoires et bien sûr ça serait la
décision du président Poutine lui-même
parler avec le président Poutine Noël
plus de sens
le Kremlin affirme que attaque
ukrainienne sur ses territoires
nouvellement annexés sera considéré par
la Russie comme une attaque contre
elle-même est-ce que vous craignez une
escalade en raison des dernières
décisions prises par Moscou
par cette allusion au bombardements
récents la Russie continue ses
opérations offensives au bombasses
nous constatons que la mobilisation de
force supplémentaires se poursuit donc
qui parle d'escalade on doit pas être
effrayé par cette escalade l'escalade a
déjà commencé du côté russe et nous
devons renforcer nos capacités pour
dissuader la Russie et pour les expulser
du territoire ukrainien le chef adjoint
du renseignement militaire ukrainien a
récemment déclaré que l'utilisation
d'armes tactique nucléaire par la Russie
le risque était je le cite très élevé
est-ce que cette nouvelle donne rend ce
risque encore plus élevé
que la Russie cherche à semer la peur et
cherche à paralyser tout le monde avec
cette peur
que elle pourrait utiliser l'arme
nucléaire sous sa forme tactique c'est
un acte de désespoir
parce qu'il perde la guerre sur le
terrain
il faut prendre ce message sérieusement
mais n'oublions pas que le monde est en
mesure de dissuader la Russie et je suis
sûr que les autres pays nucléaires vont
se poser fermement à cette utilisation
de l'arme nucléaire
ce qui est un petit peu étrange dans
cette situation c'est que dans les
territoires que la Russie clame être son
territoire ils n'ont pas le contrôle
total et même à donner ce que dans la
région dans la ville de coupianz que
dans le 9 ferroviaire de Liman
les forces ukrainiennes font des progrès
en ce moment même est-ce que c'est ce
qui se passe monsieur coulib
tout à fait
la Russie
des territoires
qu'elle ne peut pas contrôler
et donc est-ce que vous pensez que Liman
se 9 février va bientôt être sous
contrôle ukrainien
je
n'affirme j'affirme uniquement quand je
sais que des villes et des villages des
territoires nous les contrôlons déjà ce
que je peux dire dans c'est déjà c'est
que notre progrès est fort dans cette
partie du pays vous avez critiqué les
nouvelles sanctions européennes qui sont
considérées après ces soi-disant
référendum qu'est-ce qui ne va pas pour
vous
vous savez c'est la première fois depuis
le 24 février que je critique cette ce
train de sanction proposée par l'Union
européenne et je le fais pour une raison
très simple parce que ça ne correspond
pas au niveau de menace
offert par la Russie contre l'Europe à
cause de cette annexation et de cette
agression continue c'est ce qui se passe
actuellement
je crois qu'il faut des sanctions plus
sectorielles qui viendrait s'ajouter au
train de sanctions existant les
sanctions personnelles c'est bien mais
l'histoire depuis 2014 a montré que les
sanctions personnelles n'étaient pas
suffisantes pour avoir un fort impact
sur la Russie à quel secteur pensez-vous
monsieur couliba
le secteur énergétique la banque et puis
la coopération nucléaire avec la
réussite d'autres secteurs encore vous
avez récemment vivement critiqué
l'Allemagne pour son refus de vous
fournir des temps qui est des véhicules
d'infanterie
est-ce que vous en voulez toujours à
l'Allemagne et peut-être à d'autres pays
occidentaux
l'Allemagne a pris d'excellentes
décisions de nous fournir des systèmes
de défense aérien aussi d'autres
systèmes de lancement de missiles
multiples mais il est également vrai
nous avons toujours besoin de
déverrouiller l'approvisionnement en
temps qui ont véhicule blindé parce
qu'ils sont fondamentaux
c'est pour ça que j'ai dit je continue
de le dire nous apprécions ce qui nous a
été donné mais si nous demandons des
temps que pour protéger l'Europe de la
Russie il faudrait qu'on nous donne 7
ans et nous allons continuer d'assister
sur ce point on va un petit peu parler
d'autre régions
africaines de nombreux pays africains
sont restés plutôt neutre en disant
c'est une guerre européenne on ne veut
pas se fâcher avec la Russie
est-ce que vous êtes surpris ou
peut-être déçu par cela non je ne suis
ni surpris ni déçue c'est la réalité
nous devons converser davantage avec
l'Afrique et avec les pays du Sud en
général et puis les esprits commencent à
changer ils se sont aperçus de deux
choses premièrement
que l'agression russe contre l'Ukraine a
des répercussions directes sur la
sécurité aliment deuxièmement que
l'Afrique a elle aussi de nombreux
conflits territoriaux si la Russie
l'emporte
des territoires en violant l'intégrité
de son voisin l'Ukraine et ce serait une
justification pour ceux qui en Afrique
veulent également changer les frontières
avec leurs voisins donc on commence à
mieux comprendre les répercussions de
l'agression en Ukraine sur les pays
africains au bout du compte je crois
qu'ils vont modifier leur politique je
veux vous faire réagir à une affirmation
de Vladimir Poutine il a dit que après
l'accord sur les céréales les
exportations
ukrainiennes vont surtout vers des pays
riches et non pas vers les pays pauvres
et notamment pas en Afrique votre
réaction
c'est un mensonge la réalité est
différente
la plupart des livraisons alimentaires
ukrainien on était envoyé en Afrique et
en Asie certains ont été en Europe mais
certainement pas la majorité
en conclusion les autorités ukrainiennes
veulent que le Vladimir Poutine soit
traduit en justice devant une course
spéciale pour le crime d'agression mais
beaucoup de pays occidentaux le
secrétaire général de l'ONU dise que
c'est la Cour pénale internationale qui
doit être chargé de rendre la justice
nous aimerions que la Cour pénale
internationale face comparaître
Poutine pour ce crime d'agression mais
il y a les obstacles juridiques pour la
CP et la Cour elle-même le reconnaît par
conséquent je crois qu'il faut trouver
d'autres solutions et je suis sûr que
nous allons les trouver dernière
question est-ce que vous pensez que
Vladimir Poutine montre sa confiance en
annexant des territoires en mobilisant
des trous ou est-ce que c'est un signe
de faiblesse
c'est un signe de faiblesse et
c'est le peuple russe qui va payer pour
cette faiblesse de ce dirigeant ça ne
sera ni le président Poutine ni les
membres de sa famille de ses amis
ni leurs enfants Les enfants de son
entourage qui sont envoyés à la
boucherie et qui mourront en Ukraine
beaucoup de Russes des hommes vont
mourir parce que Poutine ne reconnaît
pas qu'il est en train de perdre la
guerre mitro couliba merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous sur France 24
depuis Kiev et merci à vous de l'avoir
suivi
[Musique]